bienvenue à tous c'est l'heure de
Parlement Hebdo 45 minutes pour faire le
tour de l'actualité politique et
parlementaire avec Katia guilder bonjour
Katia bonjour Michael et beaucoup
d'actualité encore cette semaine à moins
de 3 semaines avant le premier tour des
élections départementales le Front
national fait la course en tête dans les
sondages et du coup elle UMP le PS se
crise pour les munitions prier d'aller
sur le terrain pour faire campagne bref
la campagne des départementales prend un
tournant national au Sénat la loi
emblématique sur la transition
énergétique a été votée les écologistes
n'ont pas donné leur voix au texte il
s'insurgent notamment contre un retour
en force du nucléaire de son côté la
ministre Ségolène Royal promet de
revenir à la version initiale de son
texte et puis on ira faire un petit tour
aussi même voir un film qui a obtenu un
Oscar citizen fort un documentaire sur
Edward Snowden vous savez c'est celui
qui a dénoncé les écoutes mondiales
exercées par les Américains c'est notre
plus de l'hebdo cette semaine notre
invité Jean-Marc Germain bonjour vous
êtes député socialiste des
Hauts-de-Seine un directeur de cabinet
de Martine Aubry tout avait si bien
commencé Jean-Marc Germain c'est le
titre de votre livre qui vient de
paraître aux éditions de l'Atelier
journal d'un frondeur vous revendiquez
l'appellation on en parlera tout à
l'heure avec notre chroniqueur Jim
jaraze mais pour commencer cette
émission je vous propose un état des
lieux du PS face à vous frondeur et bien
il y a les réformateurs qui s'organisent
en vue du Congrès prochainement
reportage de Jean-Baptiste Daoulas
il se surnomme les réformateurs et ils
veulent peser à trois mois du Congrès
l'aile droite du PS présenté hier sa
contribution sous le regard bienveillant
d'un proche de Manuel Valls le
secrétaire d'État Jean-Marie Le Guen je
dis sous l'autorité de Jean-Marie nombre
de ministres résignés s'il n'y avait pas
eu de consignes qu'aucun ministre ne
signait aucune contribution je voulais
ici vous dire combien nous y étions
engagés et attachés face aux frondeurs
les réformateurs ont réuni une
quarantaine de parlementaires avec
l'objectif de convertir l'ensemble du PS
à la politique du gouvernement dans la
salle les militants demandent à l'aile
gauche de s'adapter à la crise
économique
réellement que il faut avancer pour en
finir avec le délit de la réalité
quelques jours après le vote de la loi
Macron Gérard Collomb s'interroge sur le
maintien des frondeurs au sein du PS si
un certain nombre de membres du Parti
socialiste Banks que c'est du côté de
Monsieur mélange du côté de l'extrême
gauche que se trouve aujourd'hui la
vérité faut le dire clairement et à ce
moment-là aller sur cette Lina avec ceux
qui sont sur la même pensée que vous les
réformateurs font monter la pression
avant le congrès et lance un ultimatum
au premier secrétaire du PS c'est sûr
que nous voulons peser c'est à dire que
si demain dans la mesure de
Jean-Christophe gambadélis c'est Martine
Aubry qui écrit la motion et que nous
nous sommes pas nous ne tenons pas la
plume c'est sûr qu'il y aura des
difficultés le PS reste tiraillé entre
deux lignes de plus en plus opposées le
rassemblement du parti s'annonce d'ores
et déjà compliqué
deux lignes opposées et en même temps on
a entendu Gérard Collomb qui certains
qui espèrent vous convertir à la
politique du gouvernement c'est un peu
un comble non je crois qu'il faut
accepter le débat et pas comme le fait
Gérard Collomb dans votre partage de
dire que certains devraient quitter le
parti socialiste qui fait la force d'une
formation politique c'est d'être
nombreux enfin les le pôle des
réformateurs c'est un tout petit pôle
qui d'ailleurs incarne une ligne qui
quand il y a eu un scrutant que c'était
celle de Manuel Valls à poser 5% si je
me trompe des voix
Macron monsieur Germain on a même
entendu Bruno Leroux qui à un moment
donné a dit mais s'ils sont pas contents
qu'ils s'en aille oui mais ça il faut
éviter vraiment parce que on a des
débats qui sont compliqués je prends
l'affaire du travail du dimanche
personne ne peut prétendre que c'est ça
d'un côté ça favorise la vie des
consommateurs vous comme moi on est très
content le dimanche après-midi de
pouvoir aller dans un magasin de
bricolage quand on en a
65% trouve normal que vous opposiez
c'est votre victoire en tout cas ça fait
plaisir moi je me fixe pas et je me
détermine pas en fonction des sondages
j'en avais eu un peu moins bon avant
mais par contre je ressens vraiment ça
sur le terrain c'est j'étais encore
samedi à distribuer des tracts pour
soutenir les candidats aux élections
départementales et c'est ce que me
disent les gens et je raconte d'ailleurs
au début de mon livre je commence par
récuser un peu ce terme de frondeur
parce que moi j'ai eu l'impression de
faire tout simplement mon travail de
députés quand je suis d'accord
finalement vous l'acceptez quand je suis
d'accord je vote mais quand je suis pas
d'accord je le dis pendant deux ans je
le dis puis je finis par voter comme me
demande le premier secrétaire du Parti
socialiste ou le président de la
République et puis au bout de deux ans
je me dis lancé plus possible parce que
sinon il y a plus de Parlement mais les
gens qu'est-ce qu'ils me disent ils me
disent merci après m'avoir dit à vous
êtes un frondeur vous avez à la télé et
ils me disent merci pourquoi parce qu'à
partir du moment où je suis libre et
bien il considère que je suis l'un des
leurs et je suis pas là pour faire
carrière pour cela que le Président de
la République va vous recevoir
oui c'est une très bonne chose vous
savez moi cette idée qu'il avait lancé
dans sa campagne présidentielle de dire
je recevrai jamais les parlementaires ça
me paraît pas une bonne idée parce que
il faut prendre avec du fait que c'est
lui qui décide des lois dans notre pays
et donc il faut qu'il ait des contacts
avec les parlementaires dans différentes
formes le rendez-vous aura lieu
vous verrez quand il aura eu lieu je
crois qu'aussi il faut que qu'est-ce que
vous lui direz non mais je vous réponds
pas à votre question de quand parce que
non mais je vous explique pourquoi parce
que sinon ce qui nous écoutent vont dire
pourquoi il nous le dit pas parce que je
crois que c'est important que ce
rendez-vous soit pas une mise en scène
ni du président de la République qui
montre qui allait à l'écoute ni
défendeurs qui montent qui pèsent
quelque chose mais à un moment utile de
discussion et de compréhension moi si
j'ai écrit ce livre c'est aussi pour que
calmement en couchant sur le papier
notre démarche chacun puisse comprendre
ce qu'on a une indication c'est avant
les élections ou après ça aura lieu dans
qui viennent dans les gens qui viennent
donc certainement voir les élections
c'est un message important aussi adressé
à l'opinion oui oui c'est très bien que
le Président de la République soit à
l'écoute de tous les parlementaires pas
simplement de ceux qui nous représentent
institutionnellement qui sont importants
nos présidents de groupe le premier
secrétaire mais comme il le fait
d'ailleurs il reçoit des des groupes
différents de parlementaires là il
voulait voir entendre de lui-même ce
qu'on ce qu'on dit même si je raconte
dans le livre que moi je l'ai vu au mois
de juin en tête à tête d'autres
c'est collectif sera lieu à l'endroit
que que nous ne rendrons pas public on
n'en sera pas plus pour l'instant non
mais c'est pas l'important l'important
c'est mieux c'est qu'on discute et on va
discuter de quoi on se rendez vous c'est
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire pour le pays
nous notre souhait et mon dernier
chapitre ça s'appelle il n'est pas trop
tard pour réussir c'est comment on fait
pour réussir les deux dernières années
du quinquennat parce que notre
conviction c'est que si François
Hollande ne réussit pas personne ne
réussira aucun socialiste ni Manuel
Valls ni les frondeurs ni Gérard Collomb
ni d'autres et la France ne réussira pas
non plus allez on va passer un peu tout
l'actualité de la semaine on va
commencer par le lundi c'est normal les
élections approches
la droite la gauche se mobilise pour
lutter contre le vote du Front national
mais une autre donnée majeure arrive
avec ce scrutin c'est le risque de
l'abstention voissa avec Cécile si vous
savez qu'il y a des élections bientôt
c'est des sélections
les élections départementales n'attire
pas les foules un Français sur trois ne
serait pas au courant que les 22 et 29
mars prochain ils sont invités à aller
voter pour élire leurs conseillers
départementaux la cause selon Xavier
chino expert électoral c'est une vraie
méconnaissance de cette élection une
espèce d'usine à gaz un peu complexe où
on élit des binômes paritaire avec des
suppléants c'est pas très clair pour les
gens on a changé la taille des cantons
et la diviser par deux ce qui fait que
les cantons sont plus gros donc quand il
y avait un fait local assez fort on
connaissait son conseiller général parce
qu'il est le maire d'une grande commune
il y a une partie du canton où on ne va
plus le connaître donc ça va atténuer
l'effet vote locale au profit du vote
national conséquence 57% des Français
n'auraient pas l'intention d'aller voter
une abstention qui pourrait faire le
bonheur du FN selon un sondage odoxa le
partie de Marine Le Pen serait en tête
avec 33% des suffrages devant l'UMP et
le PS ça signifie que au soir du premier
tour dans la plupart des cantons de
France et bien on verra plus souvent des
duels entre l'UMP et le Front national
que des duels habituels gauche-droite ça
signifie sa préfigure aussi probablement
une victoire de la droite au second tour
dans un maximum de départements et en
même temps de gros problèmes pour
Nicolas Sarkozy et l'UMP sur les
arbitrages qui auront lieu dans
l'entre-deux tours le niveau de
l'abstention sera donc déterminant pour
l'accession au deuxième tour en effet
les règles électorales sont strictes il
faudra obtenir plus de 12,5% des
électeurs inscrits pour y parvenir la
crainte c'est que au premier tour votre
électorat ne se déplace pas et du coup
vous perdez les 500 coton voir 1000
cantons c'est pas si vous pronostiquez
aussi quelques chiffres oui c'est un peu
ce qui s'est passé aux municipales donc
maintenant
je crois pas pied en fait le climat est
un peu meilleur
parce que il y a il y a eu d'abord la
très bonne gestion par le Président de
la République des attentats de Paris et
Montrouge et ça nous le dise il y a les
indicateurs économiques c'est des rayons
de soleil on peut pas croire sur le
terrain que tout est tout est réglé mais
quand même ça va mieux vraiment mieux il
y a des perspectives ça est encore mieux
avec le prix du pétrole avec les taux
d'intérêt donc on sent quand même sur le
terrain ce premier élément et
deuxièmement il y a un peu plus de de
concentration vers le Parti socialiste à
gauche donc il y aura sans doute un peu
moins de dispersion je crois que les
Français ont compris qu'on avait fait
tout ce qu'on pouvait pour avoir des
listes uniques même si on a
effectivement
les communistes c'est compliqué oui
c'est compliqué et puis après moi ce que
je souhaite ce que je souhaite comment
on fait pour mobiliser les électeurs en
parlant des élections départementales on
voit bien que certains Front national
comme le président l'ancien président de
la République
en parlant de FNPS essayent de
stigmatiser enfin de de faire
des personnes en tout cas politique il y
a aussi le fond de ce sur quoi en vote
les départementales comment est-ce que
vous pouvez convaincre des Français
d'aller voter pour une réforme qu'on
présente comme des élections
essentielles alors même que les les
compétences des départements ne sont pas
encore clairement fixés parce que la loi
n'est pas votée on a tardé sur ce sujet
là mais maintenant les choses sont
claires les transports ont été
transférés à la région le reste ça va au
département et ensuite il y aura un
processus un peu au cas par cas qui
permettra de transférer d'autres
compétences quand les élus le décideront
soit vers les métropoles soit vers les
régions donc les choses sont claires il
y a des départements ils gardent des
compétences très fort maintenant faut
voter pour ceux que vous considérez le
plus à même de porter les politiques de
solidarité moi c'est le seul message que
je veux faire passer aux électeurs bien
compris alors mardi justement d'en
parler il y a eu beaucoup de réactions à
l'Assemblée après ces fameux propos pour
vous parler de Nicolas Sarkozy
votez au premier tour pour le FNC faire
gagner la gauche au second dixit Nicolas
Sarkozy selon lui c'est le FNPS et bien
cette formule a fait beaucoup réagir
elle est socialiste dénonce une manœuvre
politicienne de l'UMP avant les
élections élisabetholomé en tête des
suffrages c'est ceux qui pourraient se
passer au prochain élections
départementales selon plusieurs sondages
le Front national pourrait obtenir
jusqu'à 33% des voix pour la droite ce
score du parti d'extrême droite n'a
qu'une seule explication et nous
constatons aujourd'hui que c'est le
parti socialiste qui cherche une bouée
de sauvetage dans la montée du Front
national pour se maintenir au pouvoir
mais je crois qu'il va se reprendre le
boomerang dans la figure puisque
désormais le Parti socialiste risque de
sortir du jeu depuis la présidence de
François Mitterrand la droite accuse le
PS de favoriser la montée du Front
national hier dans une interview au
Figaro Nicolas Sarkozy utilisait même la
nul et FNPS une manière de renvoyer les
deux parties dos à dos une position
qualifiée de slogan par le président du
groupe socialiste Nicolas Sarkozy essaye
de trouver des slogans pour cacher le
manque d'idées et ce n'est pas bon pour
la démocratie ce n'est pas avec des
slogans que l'on arrive à résoudre la
chose quand on plus le principal
problème c'est bien la porosité
aujourd'hui entre l'électorat de droite
et l'électorat du Front national selon
un récent sondage 19% des électeurs
ayant voté pour Nicolas Sarkozy au
premier tour de la présidentielle en
2012 souhaite la victoire du Front
National au départemental
alors votre commentaire sur cette
formule FNPS maladresse formule sans
intérêt ou bien erreur politique
je trouve que dans la bouche d'un ancien
président de la République c'est très
grave parce que au fond depuis des
décennies la gauche et la droite on
partageait ensemble la République la
République c'est quoi c'est l'idée du
vivre ensemble face à un parti le Front
National qui stigmatise l'étranger qui
veut sortir de l'Europe qui défend le
rétablissement de la peine de mort
maintenant inscrite dans la constitution
de notre République donc et là pour vous
et là il brille ça Jean-François Copé
l'avait fait mais enfin c'était pas la
dimension politique
assez loin pour que ça rebondisse dans
le débat voilà oui mais quand on est une
personnalité de cette dimension quand on
a incarné la France on n'a pas le droit
de faire ça on doit parler de ses idées
et moi j'ai lu dans le Figaro un certain
bidet j'étais un peu déçu d'ailleurs
c'était celle de 2007 qui reviennent ces
proposition
totalement daté enfin
stigmatiser enfin stigmatiser s'attaquer
à la fonction publique alors c'est tout
y passe suppression des grilles de
rémunération c'est des 5 ans à la place
des emplois augmentation du temps de
travail enfin il a une espèce
d'obsession non remplacement d'un
fonctionnaire sur deux dans les
commentaires enfin c'est de la folie
quoi ce qui fait la force de la France
c'est ses services publics moi je suis
responsable de
l'internationaliste tout le monde me dit
vous avez une chance le votre trésor
c'est vos services publics c'est vos
collectivités locales et lui nous
programmes une casse de ça et puis
toutes ces propositions là il y en a pas
une de nouvelles moi je suis assez
critique sur un certain nombre
d'économies qui sont faites par le
gouvernement les fameux 50 milliards
même si je pense qu'il faut être sérieux
il faut réduire les déficits mais lui
c'est pas 50 qui propose c'est 150
milliards et je sais pas si vous avez
noté mais sur quoi il insiste les
politiques de formation professionnelle
la formation c'est la compétitivité de
et le logement après les les attentats
et tout ce que ça a révélé de malaise
dans les banlieues dans le logement est
une des clés la mixité sociale aussi
donc il a des réponses non seulement
datées il sait pas du tout renouvelé
mais en plus qui sont dangereuses pour
le pays si elles devaient être mise en
œuvre donc moi ça me non seulement je
trouve qu'il se comporte mal très
franchement j'espère que il va quitter
cela parce que c'est détestable les
Français ont besoin de repères
républicains le Premier ministre et le
président de la République les ont
rappelé admirablement en ce mois de
janvier et puis deuxièmement là on a un
débat politique tout à fait noble c'est
des idées différentes et moi je respecte
les siennes et je les critique avec les
miennes nous partons au Sénat cette fois
avec une loi phare du gouvernement qui a
été évité sa substance le texte soit
transition énergétique il a été
largement remanié au Sénat on voit ça
avec Flora sauvage c'est une coquille
vide ou presque la loi sur la transition
énergétique a été vidée de sa substance
après son passage
la chambre haute a supprimé l'objectif
de 2025 pour réduire la part du
nucléaire à 50% dans la production
d'électricité je suis un peu déçu parce
que pour nous cette un point
d'achoppement
et c'est d'ailleurs parce que cette
disposition a été adoptée que j'ai été
contraint je dis bien la mort dans l'âme
de demander à ce que nous nous
abstenions autre ajout du Sénat la
capacité maximale de la production
d'électricité d'origine nucléaire est
augmentée alors même que le gouvernement
voulait la plafonner à 63,2 gigawatts
pour les écologistes qui ont voté contre
le texte la loi sur la transition
énergétique est un retour au tout
nucléaire sa loi n'est pas crédible
c'est loi qui est loi de transition
énergétique fait tout pour maintenir le
mix énergétique électrique français tel
qu'il est aujourd'hui ce qui n'a aucun
sens y compris dans le contexte
économique européen donc voilà donc
c'est un peu là dessus un baroud
d'honneur aussi du Sénat de la majorité
UMP qu'il ne pouvait pas à ne pas
combattre cet aspect du texte en
commission mixte paritaire député et
sénateurs vont devoir trouver un
compromis à défaut l'assemblée aura le
dernier mot
tout à l'heure entre la gauche et à
droite et le débat sur le nucléaire là
vous avez là aussi un grand débat oui
c'est normal au fond j'espère et je me
réjouis que la ministre de l'écologie
les annoncé que le l'Assemblée nationale
reviendra sur son texte de départ qui
est totalement essentiel enfin le
l'affaire du réchauffement climatique
c'est la question majeure de notre
génération politique sinon on n'est pas
capable de résoudre ces problèmes dans
ces lois là à la conférence de Paris et
dans les années qui viendront le
réchauffement aura lieu et les désastres
qui vont avec humain écologiques et
économiques alors il y a une autre
décision qui qui vient de tomber à
l'instant elle concerne le barrage de le
site de sylvens le Conseil Général du
vient de décider de voter pour un site
réduit pour un projet de barrage réduit
voilà la décision il demande aussi
l'expulsion sans délai des occupants un
commentaire sur cette décision il faut
regarder ce que ça veut dire réduit
parce que si c'est réduit après ce que 0
ou si c'est le projet initial
reconfiguré avec trois bassins de même
taille ça change un peu tout mais que je
voudrais dire sur cette affaire c'est
que c'est pas normal qu'on en arrive là
parce que les questions qu'on posait les
écologistes et les adultes elles sont
très bonnes et on le voit d'ailleurs la
ministre a dit il y a un problème le
projet a été mal a été mal étudié et en
même temps il doit y avoir une place
pour pour l'agriculture pour des
retenues d'eau et on doit être capable
d'étudier si ça bouleverse ou pas
l'environnement donc je crois qu'il faut
aussi repenser les méthodes de
concertation objectivement la
concertation soit elle était pas
suffisamment poussée soit été mal prise
en compte je pense qu'il faudra
réfléchir à une loi sur sur quelque part
la situation on la laisse un petit peu
pourrir de ce côté déjà du côté de
Sylvain oui sur le fond surtout parce
qu'après quand il y a des désaccords
aussi sur les années qui occupent encore
oui mais ça c'est difficile vous savez
gérer des questions
d'ordre public dans ces cas-là ou on
voit bien que les agriculteurs comme les
adient ce qu'ils expriment c'est avec
leur cœur aussi
d'un côté comme de l'autre il défendent
leurs production alors capacité de
production d'un côté
je crois que le ministre le Premier
ministre et le ministre de l'Intérieur a
raison de dire que maintenant il faut
que la démocratie reprenne le dessus le
débat
les actions ont permis de poser le débat
au plan national et que maintenant on
travaille de manière démocratique sur
les solutions parce qu'on peut pas non
plus tout le temps s'opposer aux
décisions des élus sinon il y a plus de
démocratie représentative dans dans ce
pays-là donc mais je vous dis encore une
fois le fond du problème et on l'a vu
aussi sur Notre Dame des Landes c'est
qu'on soit capable de faire des vraies
concertations qui étudi dient tous les
problèmes parce que à chaque fois les
écologistes sont posées devant vos
questions respect de leur public alors
on passe à mercredi Christiane Taubira
est à nouveau dans le collimateur de la
droite
un tract ambulant pour le FN ce sont les
propos d'un député
UMP Gérald Darmanin au sujet de
Christiane Taubira réaction immédiate de
la guerre des sceaux ainsi que de
manuels aussi
Gérald Darmanin ne s'attendait pas une
telle riposte après ses propos
qualifiant la garde des sceaux de
tractambulant pour le FN le député du
Nord c'est d'abord attirer les foudres
du Premier ministre hier
c'était le propos et nous le permettrons
jamais on signe de soutien les députés
PS sont offert une standing ovation à
Christiane Taubira la cible préférée de
l'opposition qui n'a besoin de personne
pour se défendre elle considère les
attaques du jeune député comme rien de
moins que des déchets de la pensée
humaine ce matin à la sortie du Conseil
des ministres elle ajoutait une salve
franchement je trouverai pitoyable que
malgré son jeune âge peut-être même du
fait de son jeune âge sans doute à cause
de la déliquescence de son parti il en
soit contraint à s'exprimer à tenir des
propos qui ne soit pas éclairé par un
idéal républicain moi je trouve ça
pitoyable si je arrête de la pitié à
gaspiller ça n'est pas le cas pour ce
monsieur des élus de droite sont venus
au secours de leurs collègues Christian
Jacob estiment que les déclarations de
Christiane Taubira sont ignobles et dans
un tweet Xavier Bertrand jusque ses
propos ne sont pas dignes d'un ministre
de son côté Gérald Darmanin persistent
et signe et a reçu le soutien unanime de
tout son parti dans un communiqué publié
par l'UMP
alors ces propos de Gérald Darmanin
petite phrase pour faire du buzz ou
propos raciste selon vous
même pas les qualifier mais moi j'ai
envie de dire ça suffit en permanence
Christiane Taubira est attaqué par la
droite avec des propos qui ont des
relents nauséabonds à chaque fois à la
limite de du propos raciste en effet en
jouant sur les mots sur les allusions
sous les anges sous-entendus il faut il
faut arrêter c'est un ministre de la
République qui fait bien son travail qui
le fait main dans la main en ce qui
concerne les questions de sécurité avec
Manuel Valls puis avec Bernard Cazeneuve
qui a porté une magnifique loi du
mariage pour tout je crois aussi
il y a aussi ça derrière c'est qu'ils
ont jamais pardonné le brio avec elle
elle portait cette loi là sembler
nationale mais moi je dis ça suffit on
peut pas attaquer une ministre de la
République comme ça alors Jean-Marc
Germain on va accueillir à présent notre
partenaire du Figaro pour un décryptage
de l'actu c'est la loupe du scan
bonjour
et vous allez nous reparler du livre de
Jean-Marc Germain bonjour Jean-Marc
Germain vous avez donc publié un livre
il s'appelle tout avait si bien commencé
ça veut dire que ça c'est en train de
mal évoluer vous y évoquez donc les
premiers jours du quinquennat de
François Hollande le camp de la gauche
était unie auréolé de toutes ses
victoires électorales à quand date-vous
précisément le basculement le jour où
vous êtes dit nous socialiste on va dans
le mur avec ce quinquennat il y a eu
deux étapes je les raconte dans le livre
un certain nombre de mécontentements
mais assez naturel la loi bancaire
qu'elle est pas assez loin le traité
constitutionnel qui n'était pas
renégocier mais le crédit d'impôt
compétitivité emploi sans contrepartie
pour les entreprises décembre 2012 ça
c'était le premier coup voilà et puis
rebelote janvier 2014 où on double la
mise et toujours sans contrepartie moi
je dis oui pour aider les entreprises
mais si on demande rien en échange ça
fait du dividende et ce qu'il faut
demander comme effort aux Français n'est
pas acceptable et ne fonctionne pas
économiquement donc après les
municipales on décide effectivement en
tant que parlementaire de dire bah on va
non seulement de notre voix ce qu'on a
commencé à faire en mais de notre vote
pour que ça puisse changer et la loi
Macron c'est la goutte d'eau
alors vous vous êtes en adversaire
résolu du droit de dissolution du
président et alors là vous prenez votre
smartphone et vous préparez un tweet
c'est un socialiste dites-vous qui a
théorisé le coup d'état permanent c'est
un autre qui l'a expérimenté qu'il
expérimente pardon aujourd'hui alors ce
tweet on l'a reconstitué parce que
finalement vous l'avez pas publié vous
avez considéré que c'était peut-être
trop caricatural est-ce que après
l'épisode de la du 49-3 de la loi Macron
vous regrettez de ne pas avoir publié ce
tweet non parce que je crois quand on
fait ce genre de tweet on fait des
polémiques et on parle pas du fond en
revanche le fond j'étais vraiment en
colère ce jour là parce que la
Constitution elle dit quoi elle dit s'il
y a pas la confiance le président de la
République doit présenter soit le même
gouvernement avec un autre programme
politique soit un autre gouvernement et
là ça renverse totalement les choses au
fond ça revient à nier le Parlement ça
veut dire soit vous vous soumettez à
tout ce que je souhaite avec l'exécutif
soit je vous démêle et si on fait ça non
seulement le Parlement n'existe plus
j'ai problème en démocratie mais surtout
le Parlement j’explique ça dans le livre
c'est une valeur ajoutée énorme le
travail qu'on fait et si on le considère
comme quand tu es négligeable il y a
plus aucun moment ou entre l'idée d'un
exécutif qui est dans son rôle quand il
propose et ce qui devient réalité ben il
y a toute la consultation des Français à
travers les parlementaires qui est
totalement vous allez lui dire de la
République comme vous allez voir que
c'est l'homme du coup d'état permanent
non je dirais pas d'ailleurs je l'ai pas
je l'ai jamais dit mais dans votre livre
quand même je je dis en revanche que
d'avoir prononcé cette phrase était une
erreur c'est bien sûr son droit
d'utiliser de la dissolution mais d'en
faire une règle comme il l'a fait de
cette manière là c'est-à-dire attention
pour l'avenir s'il y a pas la confiance
il y aura la dissolution ça ça va pas
parce qu'il faut vraiment qu'on se dise
et qu'on dédramatise au fond le rôle
d'un gouvernement c'est de trouver une
majorité à l'Assemblée nationale sur un
texte sur le dimanche d'avoir trouvé un
accord sur le nombre de dimanches je
travaille par exemple dans une dépêche
AFP publié la semaine dernière vous
appelez à la constitution d'un nouveau
contrat de majorité avec les radios de
gauche avec les écologistes vous dites
si ça doit se traduire par un nouveau
gouvernement ça renforce la chose vous
dites même je n'ai jamais su
personnellement les responsabilités
est-ce que ça veut dire que vous êtes
prêts à rentrer dans un éventuel
gouvernement encadrement par exemple
après les élections départementales j'ai
été je l'ai dit aussi responsable des
grandes lois du quinquennat à
l'Assemblée nationale j'étais rapporteur
sur les emplois d'avenir j'étais aussi
rapporteur sur nous un peu plus
polémique était la loi de sécurisation
de l'emploi donc j'ai toujours été là
pour accompagner le gouvernement mais
avec une exigence c'est au fond d'être
fidèle à ce qu'on a promis à nos
électeurs et puis la deuxième moi je
suis économiste c'est de faire ce que je
pense
donc pour le pays donc je redis ce que
j'ai dit exactement la priorité c'est
qu'on est un contrat de gouvernement qui
réunissent tous ceux qui ont porté
François Hollande c'est-à-dire les
écologistes l'ensemble de la gauche le
soutien peut-être participation des
communistes c'est ça la priorité après
le retour des Verts après il faut oui je
souhaite le retour des Verts il faudra
que ça s'incarne dans un gouvernement
ensuite et dans l'ensemble des
socialistes et toutes les sensibilités
dans ce que gouvernement ça met
franchement égal moi je suis prêt à
l'aide parce que j'ai jamais fui les
responsabilités mais moi mon bonheur
sera total si ce qu'on fait me convient
peuvent cohabiter au sein d'un
gouvernement avec par exemple Emmanuel
Macron qui a qualifié les frondeurs de
foyer infectieux sont des mots très
forts est-ce qu'on peut encore cohabiter
dans une dans une telle ambiance écoutez
je crois que Manuel Macron était au ski
quand il a prononcé ses phrases on
appelle ça une faute de car et ça arrive
quand on se laisse griser par la vitesse
donc je mets ça sur le compte de son
inexpérience mais faut pas prononcer des
mots comme ça en politique quand on a
des débats difficiles comme on a des
décisions difficiles à prendre pour la
France je crois que le première chose à
faire c'est de respecter les positions
des autres il aurait moi je pense que
c'est bon pour la France mais je
respecte les positions de ceux qui sont
pas d'accord ça me serait très bien
aller et j'aurais accepté dans ce cas
l'utilisation du 49-3 qui au fond là
pour dire on est d'accord pour continuer
ensemble c'est pour ça que j'ai pas voté
la motion de censure mais on a un
désaccord sur cette loi merci beaucoup
Jim pour votre éclairage on va rester à
mercredi on va aller au Sénat cette fois
avec un rêve qui devait réalité ce rêve
c'est celui d'Armando Curie il a reçu la
médaille du meilleur apprenti menuisier
de France une décoration qui a été qui
aurait pu lui être refusé à ce
sans-papier albanais avant que son cas
ne soit médiatisé que la situation
évidemment ne change on va regarder ça
avec Louis Sibille
de l'ombre à la lumière ce jeune immigré
albanais devient aujourd'hui meilleur
apprenti de France
c'est la première fois que ça m'arrive
sous les ordres de la République on se
moquing et nœud papillon il reçoit sa
médaille couronnement de trois ans de au
fond de mon cœur enfin je réalisais mon
rêve que je pense qu'il me puisse
féliciter comme tout le monde et voilà
enfin j'ai obtenu tout ce que je voulais
c'est l'histoire d'un parcours
incroyable entre clandestinement en
France il atterrit à Saint-Étienne à 16
ans seul sans un sous un poche il entame
un CAP de menuiserie travaille beaucoup
et apprend le français rapidement et
Armando quand les premiers temps il me
disait monsieur je comprends pas ça et
je lui ai expliqué il écrivait sur son
petit cahier et je savais que le
lendemain ou la fois prochaine qu'il
avait ce terme technique il l'avait
acquis un conte de fées qui aurait pu
virer au cauchemar en situation
irrégulière Armando Curie devait quitter
le territoire depuis octobre dernier
dans ces conditions le Sénat d'abord
refusé de l'accueillir le président du
Sénat s'en explique examiné le dossier
hier en arrivant et j'ai pris la
décision après avoir informé le cabinet
du ministre de l'Intérieur d'accueillir
ce jeune parce qu'il était le symbole
d'une réussite parce qu'il était aussi
porté par des maîtres d'apprentissage et
que les meilleurs ouvriers de France
portaient un certain nombre de valeurs
s'il vous plaît grâce à l'émotion
suscité Armando a pu bénéficier in
extremis d'un titre de séjour de 3 mois
et espérer être régularisé en mes
prochains
c'est la médaille
que ça change un peu ma vie après cette
folle journée décisive pour sa carrière
Armando Curie repart dans la Loire il
commence un bac pro le sourire aux
lèvres
pour la belle histoire d'amour
il y en a des dizaines en France qui ne
sont pas médiatisés cela faut leur
donner des papiers à tous pas à tous il
y a des critères mais en revanche il se
passe des choses dans les préfectures
qui sont pas acceptables moi j'en reçois
dans mes permanences ils arrivent même
pas à prendre de rendez-vous je crois
qu'il faut être très clair faut
accueillir tous ceux qu'on peut
accueillir parce qu'on voit bien que
c'est des talents pour la France pour
l'économie pour l'économie française
mais quand on les accueille il faut être
capable de le faire dans de bonnes
conditions c'est ça qui est difficile à
trouver mais ce qui essaie de lancer
Manuel Valls mais qui est pas encore sur
le terrain c'est que les règles soient
claires les dossiers soient étudiés
rapidement on va faire des progrès sur
un autre sujet qui est celui de l'asile
et que ça se traduise dans la vie
quotidienne de ces gens qui vivent des
situations invraisemblables on passe au
jeudi les mers ont rendez-vous avec le
Premier ministre
l'Association des maires de France avait
rendez-vous à Matignon objectif demandé
un gel de la baisse des dotations aux
collectivités pour seul gain de cause
ils ont obtenu un groupe de travail et
un nouveau rendez-vous en mai prochain
écoutez à ce sujet leur président
François baron il a entendu c'est un
ancien élu local et le sens du dialogue
il nous a et nous sommes d'accord
là-dessus fixés un calendrier cours
c'est-à-dire d'ici fin mai dans un
groupe de travail commun entre les
services de Matignon et ceux des maires
de France pour avoir un diagnostic
partagé et trouver les meilleures
réponses pour préserver l'investissement
et donc pour préserver le rôle d'acteur
économique que nous jouons nous
collectivités
alors Jean-Marc Germains on est
actuellement des choses la hausse des
impôts locaux s'annonce inévitable même
la Cour des comptes le dit il y aura
sans doute une hausse des impôts locaux
mais moi je soutiens totalement la
position de l'AMF qui est d'ailleurs
partagé à droite et à gauche on a vu le
président Elvis président à l'image et
je fais une proposition très simple qui
coûte pas un euro de plus c'est à dire
vous savez il y a une baisse d'impôts
qui a été prévue pour les entreprises ça
s'appelle la C3S la cotisation des
sociétés pour la sécurité sociale ça va
faire 5 milliards dans les deux ans à
venir dans trois milliards dès l'année
prochaine évitons cette baisse là que
personne ne demandait vraiment sauf
certains cercles patronaux de manière
confidentielle vous en avez jamais
entendu parler dans les médias et
mettons-les sur l'investissement dans
les territoires transports en commun
logement dans les banlieues on a vu les
besoins qu'il y avait dans les zones
rurales la montée du Front national ça
avoir aussi avec le fait que certaines
zones se sentent oubliées de la
République et dans les collectivités
local parce que la proximité c'est elle
qui la font et si elles ont pas les
moyens de la faire alors cette
république française qui se délite un
peu faut pas exagérer non plus va se
déliter encore plus donc je crois que
c'est vraiment essentiel c'est peut-être
si j'avais une chose à demander au
président de la République c'est de
reprendre cette proposition il y a 5
milliards qu'on peut faire basculer d'un
endroit à un autre et vous savez ce sera
une espèce de plan Marshall pour les
territoires sera une grande force pour
la France sera la meilleure réponse de
long terme aux attentats de Paris de mon
rouge vous aurez l'occasion de lui en
parler c'est quoi en fait vous êtes
tenace mais moi aussi juste un peu
frondeur un sujet qui touche les élus
locaux comme vous êtes plutôt exposition
universelle ou plutôt organisation des
JO à Paris ce que j'arrive pas bien voir
c'est s'il faut choisir parce que si on
peut faire les deux tant mieux mais ça
coûte certains défend l'idée que les
investissements et les infrastructures
pourront servir aux deux à ce moment-là
faisons les moi j'ai en tout cas
beaucoup
ce qui est la démarche de la mère de
Paris sur les Jeux Olympiques
c'est-à-dire on fait des jeux sérieux on
fait des jeux où c'est le mouvement
sportif qui est mis qui est mis en avant
et on se donne et on se donne on se
donne les moyens de gagner le mois de
candidature mais l'exposition
universelle c'est aussi les deux quelque
chose de très très important pour la
France voilà les deux mais attention en
défendant les deux de pas perdre les
deux c'est ça qu'il faut vérifier il
faut pas se tromper là dessus vous
emmener au cinéma c'est le plus de
l'hebdo
citizen fort c'est le nom du film c'est
aussi le pseudo qui avait Edward Snowden
ce film récompensé de la noscar si au
plus près les révélations de l'ancien
employé de la NSA sur l'espionnage
mondial du gouvernement américain et le
séisme bien sûr qui a suivi Simon
barbarie a vu le film il vous explique
est connue celle d'un ancien
informaticien de l'Agence nationale de
sécurité américaine qui un jour de juin
2013 décide de révéler comment la NSA
espionne les citoyens du monde entier ce
que l'on ne savait pas en revanche c'est
que le désormais célèbre lanceur
d'alerte avait été filmé avant pendant
et après ces échanges d'informations la
journaliste d'investigation Laura
Poitras en attiré un documentaire
récompensé d'un Oscar citizen fort
magnifique
Edward Snowden fait preuve d'un flegme
impressionnant face à un tel enjeu celui
de la surveillance de masse par la plus
grande démocratie du monde les
États-Unis concentre au fond de choses
un
que c'est eux qui comptent parmi les
meilleurs et les plus grandes
plateformes que nous utilisons dans
notre quotidien et puis la deuxième
chose c'est tous les outils que les
services de sécurité de l'enseignement
peuvent utiliser pour capter donc la
surveillance des tas qu'on a pu voir à
ce moment-là elle a été révélée par
semaine de Russie où son autorisation de
ces jours a été renouvelée pour 3 ans
Édouard Snowden a félicité la
documentariste Laura Poitras les
citoyens ordinaires lorsqu'ils
travaillent ensemble peuvent changer le
monde a-t-il déclaré
aujourd'hui un héros faut juste savoir
quand même que et la France et l'Europe
de lavent pas forcément aider quand il a
décidé de fuir la menace des États-Unis
elle sort d'alerte c'est toujours utile
mais on voit bien que les États n'ont
pas fait forcément nécessaire oui oui
toujours c'est un film qui donne
vraiment envie de le voir c'est assez
fabuleux ce qui a réalisé la
documentariste et puis ce qu'il a fait
salutaire parce que il y a un moment
donné moi je suis assez en soutien de
tout ce qui permet d'assurer la sécurité
d'un territoire mais en revanche une
exigence absolue c'est qu'il y a un
contrôle démocratique or là il a pas eu
lieu sur ces questions là qu'on sache
qui est fait comment et dans quelle
limite ça veut pas dire de suivre chaque
action des services secrets mais d'en
avoir un contrôle absolu et une
connaissance du public sur ce qui est
fait et l'occurrence c'était pas le cas
oui mais c'est pratique perdure en même
temps on voit que Big Brother une longue
vie devant lui oui par exemple que
depuis ce moment-là les ministres du
gouvernement français ont des téléphones
cryptés par exemple
voilà il y a eu des mesures qui ont été
prises même si on pourra jamais éviter
les choses mais le fait qu'on ait appris
par exemple que les dirigeants allemands
français etc écouter
et non protégé c'était quelque chose de
très important pour la démocratie
il faut qu'on se protège contre ça c'est
un souveraineté qui est en cause
merci beaucoup Jean-Marc jardin d'avoir
été invité de Parlement et merci et on
se retrouve la semaine prochaine la
semaine prochaine même lieu même heure
merci à tous de votre fidélité et restez
avec nous sur la chaîne parlementaires
LCP Public Sénat très bonne suite du
programme